قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
روسيا ستستخدم اليورانيوم المنظم اذا تم
ارساله ذخائر مماثله الى اوكرانيا واضاف
بوتين ان بلاده ارسلت 10 مقاتلات الى
بيلاروسيا قادره على حمل اسلحه نوويه اضاف
الرئيس الروسي ان روسيا سترسل اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه الى بيلاروسيا واوضح كذلك ان
ارسال اسلحه نوويه الى مسك لن ينتهك
المعاهدات الدوليه او اتفاقيات عدم انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه وشراب بوتين الى ان بلاده
لا تنقل اسلحتها النوويه الى بيلاروسيا بل
تعيد تموضعها كما فعلت امريكا في اوروبا
على حد قوله
لا نعطي بيلاروسيا اسلحه نوويه بل ببساطه
ننقل اسلحتنا الى هناك مثل ما تفعل
الولايات المتحده منذ عقود لقد سلمنا
بالفعل لا بيلاروسيا منظومه اسكندر
المعروفه والفعاله للغايه في الثالث من
ابريل سنبدا تدريب الطاقه وفي الاول من
يوليو سننتهي من بناء منشاه تخزين خاصه
للاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه على اراضي